[Music]
well good evening welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight say what you will about
cable news it's not a subtle medium you
don't need to do a lot of guessing about
what the anchors think they tend to tell
you over and over and over again so
what's on their mind over at MSNBC and
CNN let's see
during yesterday's marathon Michael
Cohen stormy Daniels coverage talking
heads on those channels used a single
word 222 times the word impeachment
impeachment territory impeachment
ultimately potentially an impeachment
impeachment impeachment a giant step
toward impeachment impeachment
immediately impeachment impeachment
impeachment and there's certainly enough
to impeach the president right now
impeachment for the high crime of being
shaken down in an extortion scheme by a
pornstar girlfriend at least was his own
money by the way when members of
Congress make payoffs to avoid sex
scandals and they do it's usually a
taxpayer expense but whatever the left
is now strongly opposed to paying off
former sex partners they don't tell Bill
Clinton that they're opposed to anything
Trump is for and they're for anything
he's against that's the formula
sometimes it works out for them
sometimes a dozen often it's
embarrassing for example ms-13 one of
the deadliest criminal gangs in the
world never popular and yet once Trump
criticized that group Nancy Pelosi came
out of nowhere in support of ms-13 on
theological grounds of course having sex
on camera for money was well since time
began considered disreputable and then
stormy Daniels attacks the president at
a press conference and now that she's a
member of the resistance porn is noble
just last night the left which says it
strongly opposes bigotry that I was
telling you that defended racially
motivated property seizure because the
president said he opposed it in a tweet
will of warned that in a minute you see
what's going on here
it's Pavlovian and it raises an
interesting question if the left exists
only to oppose anything that trump does
or says that isn't Trump in control of
the left's message and if that's true
how long before the president takes a
hard
I don't know human trafficking or for
motherhood just to see how the
Washington Post responds
it could be highly amusing mark Stein is
an author and columnist he joins us
tonight so mark why is Trump not
completely in control of Brett Stevens
his brain or the entire primetime lineup
at CNN it seems like he is I actually
think he is a couple of weeks ago there
was a story rather grisly story out of
Florida about cockroaches who call into
your ear and lay eggs in your brain
actually and actually don't laugh Tucker
because it's happening to famous media
personalities every morning they wake up
and they find that Trump has laid eggs
in their brain and these little Trump
roaches are running around inside their
heads driving with the nuts the ms-13
one was a classic thing these are guys
who use machetes on people and chop chop
them up in very brutal ways and he
called them animals and immediately
everyone said oh you can't you can't a
bear it's outrageous to dehumanize these
people and then it's taken to the next
level and they start presenting them as
actually nice young lads in the
neighborhood who ride around on bicycles
and have part-time jobs after schools
there straight out of Leave It to Beaver
except for the tattoos and machetes and
and and Trump manages to do that every
time as you said it's it doesn't even
have to be anything big it can be a
tweet about Aretha Franklin and they go
bananas well last night I mean let me
just say I know a number of South
African some of them very liberal for
whatever it's worth I've never met one
who will defend the government in South
Africa it's corrupt it's isn't clearly
racially motivated in the way that it
acts Trump tweets a question about the
behavior of the South African government
last night and all of a sudden he's a
bigot for questioning it and the left
finds itself on the same side does Rama
pose alike do they really want to be
there do you think no and actually it's
ridiculous the way they try to object to
what he's saying you know some of the
people who didn't like either your
report or the president's tweet was
saying oh well you know farm
killings are at a nineteen-year low in
South Africa the fact that farm killings
is a category in South African crime
statistics tells you what's going on and
just for the record even as they're
tweeting this rubbish just last night a
70 year old woman was beaten to death on
a South African and they lie about those
stats I mean the idea that we take the
stats the politically charged statistics
released by the South African government
at face value oh well in fact checking
with their statistics like more on among
that's no credible social scientists
would take that at face value obviously
no no and actually you should always
listen very carefully Tucker when
someone's telling you to shut up because
that's the left is doing and Ann Coulter
was on your show a couple of nights back
and gets a bit twitchy because the
president isn't doing more as she sees
it but in fact actually by talking about
these things by actually saying it's
necessary to expand the conversation and
not let yourself be shriveled into the
tiny little corner of things that the
left will permit you to talk about
that's actually quite important MSNBC
and CNN just think we should they talk
about celebrating diversity but in fact
they want to enforce homogeneity we're
only allowed to talk about the same
things and only allowed to have the same
perspectives on their on the same things
too and and God bless the president for
occasionally wanting to talk about
something MSNBC doesn't want to talk
exactly shut up and obey that is their
program work thank you for that
insightful as always